Wrap it up.
I want to talk about a couple of things
at the beginning and then one time it,
the suburbs at the end with, cause that's
going to be a big problem, you know, uh,
in the future. And I guess a
couple of things in the beginning,
uh, in somewhat of a particular
order I suppose is this,
that, you know, you Kinda,
I kinda torn between, uh, between, uh,
you know,
and taking about Paris,
one of the old alliances that you had
and the rebuilding of, of uh, you know,
I've tried to protect Paris from,
from the Pompey dues and the planners
and the horror of the tour Montparnasse
that you had this sort of classic
alliance between people on kind of the far
left like me and then kind
of traditional conservatives,
like a great French historian called
Louis Shu lea the story and in Paris.
And then, um, so I guess I
kind of feel like that in, in,
in trying to think about ways that,
you know, how important is that France,
France remain France and,
and uh,
I mentioned this once in passing
was talking about education,
but we got involved in our fields and
trying to save our one room school house,
uh,
because if we lose our school,
then we just start another beautiful
place full of a mob by German and Belgian
and northern French tourists,
uh,
in the summer Dutch
also. And um, you know,
if things change and,
and uh, regional, uh,
a one room school houses
disappear because I mean,
people say that that's progress and,
and, and uh, lots about rural France,
a lot of villages that do survive
survive because they're, they're,
what you call it, biological 12th
or there they're sort of a bedroom,
a villages for people who work in
towns nearby. But lots of France,
lots of rural France really only
exists now because of tourism.
And that doesn't make, make
it a in itself. I mean,
it's important that people
survive in some way,
but that doesn't provide these places
for the kinds of a kind of vitality and,
and, uh, uh, you know, high ironic would
be is if it's, if the guid me lab, the,
uh,
the green guides for every
region [inaudible] if those
are one of the sole ways
in the long run along with cuisine,
traditions of cuisine that did help
regions maintain their identity,
that would be very sad. Indeed
they're going to do. Um,
I have great ambivalence about the
European Union and about the European
constitution and of course most of
my friends to vote against it. Uh,
and some of my friends in Leone
and in Paris voted for it. Uh,
but most of the people I know,
almost all of them,
whether they were provincial academics
or whether they're very ordinary people
producing cheese or getting buy in every
way, they can, uh, voted against it.
And one of the things that they're
going to do now, which is a,
it doesn't mean anything to most people,
but it still reflects the kinds of
changes that Europe is apt to bring that
Europe in quotes,
it's apt to bring to French regions is
that they're going to get rid of the
license plates. Um, which
seems like a silly thing,
but one of the things that I
always do when I'm driving,
which I drive constantly, uh,
in France as you see, you know,
I see cars go by and see a 23, you
think, oh, the clothes, that's the,
that's a really rare bird is the least
populated department after the air and
France.
And you kind of imagine this person with
a 23 is going up to see his or her age
at grandmother and the Moselle 57.
And you do the sort of games of where
people come from and what and what.
And I mean that's interesting
and it's important,
but they're going to get rid of the
license plates and then all the license
plates will be just very much the same.
And they'll look like English license
plates or, or they'll look like, um,
my German license plates.
I don't know if they're going to get rid
of those two or the K for corn or the
beef for Berlin and all of this business.
And it's just one of the sort of threats
to the way things are that, that, that,
that the European Union has brought.
And there a lot of people at Yale and
including some of my friends were a big of
union European Union people. But you
know, we have friends who scraped by,
they produce goat's cheese and
they, uh, uh, they, um, uh,
our toll now that they must conform
to European Union rules, which are,
which are barked out in Brussels
with full of these empty apartment.
I mean an empty office buildings that
were overbuilt or barked out from
[inaudible], which is another
important capital, the European Union.
And it tells them that they, uh, that
they, uh, have to produce, uh, uh,
produce a cheese in a very
different way. And, um, you know,
I'm part of old France will disappear. But
in a way, I mean it, you know, it's sad.
I don't want every part of France to
be like every other part of France.
And we had to really struggle to, to, to,
to arrive in a world and where you have
actually TV announcer speaking with an
accent that's not a Parisian or, or a
valley of the lar accent, you know, and,
and that's very good. I'll tell
you a funny little story, um, that,
that has to do with this.
In some ways.
We have these friends who've been together
for about, uh, uh, Oh, maybe 25 years.
And like a lot of our friends and France,
they don't have any money and
they didn't ever get married.
And we have a lot of a union league. What,
I mean, they're just together. I mean,
there are a couple or as much as a
couple. It is, my wife and I are,
we've been married for 27 years.
Um, and uh, they're a one,
they have two signs and their oldest son
is my, my son's best friend. Uh, and, um,
they make goat's cheese. That's
what they do. And one day,
one summer we got this invitation
to their wedding. You know,
they'd been together for 20
years and they, you know,
when you were together for 20 years,
you're saying our best years are
behind us and all this stuff,
which isn't necessarily true,
but they were getting married,
there was sending out invitations and
the people that don't like them said, oh,
they're sending out invitations,
they're getting married because
they want to have a presence.
They want people to give them a presence,
you know,
which just went away and it's simply
not true. And then people who, you know,
like them and, and who felt, well, you
know, this is, uh, uh, you know, they're,
they're getting married because their
parents are both religious sets of parents
were fairly religious.
One Dutch, the other, uh,
Dutch Belgian and the other French from
the north of France. And so they're,
they're making it right in terms of the
church. And people said, wait a minute,
you know, is that really
the case? And so, uh, yeah,
the wedding and the wedding
was when early September.
And we couldn't go because I
was back here doing this and,
and happy to be here doing this.
Uh,
but we missed the wedding and then we
finally found out why they got married.
Probably it had something to do with
Brussels and straws war because the,
somebody went over to the
cantorial, uh, capitol.
I mean this is cap place called battle.
Uh,
and there was a big sign
that said that there,
those people who want to continue in
the new Europe to produce schools,
produce goat's cheese.
We'll have to conform to European
norms about how to do that. And,
and there'll be a course
that's offered, uh, by the, uh,
by the European Union and that we'll see.
This is about two thousands
before the shift of the whole,
maybe more about that in a minute.
And the course will cost 2000 francs,
which is a huge amount of
money for these people,
but will be free for
the wives, uh, of, uh,
for the wives of a, of
farmers. So they got married,
they were kind of forced to get married
because it would be cheaper for them to
do that. Now, that's
kind of a silly example,
but it's still the risk of Europe is that,
that people who want to live their own
lives or somehow or produce goat cheese
their own way and it produced
very good goat's cheese. Um,
so I always bring back and huge
bundles, double, triple wrapped here,
won't be allowed to do that anymore. And,
and France voted against the election,
I mean, against the constitution. And it
happened in the, in the Netherlands too.
And everybody in France,
and this plugs into what I'm gonna say
it and talk about in a minute. You know,
there's this fear of the Polish plumber,
you know, that, that's the example.
They use that because all
of these immigrants from
eastern Europe will come and,
and that the European Union's gonna have
to pay all the money to make Polish Sha
agricultural. I'll be in
Poland in two days, actually,
a back yet again, uh, make, uh,
you know, Polish agriculture, competitive
and will cost everybody a lot of money.
And that the Polish plumber will put
French plumbers out of work. And so this,
this fits into, you know, both fears
that people have, all sorts of people,
not just right wing anti-immigrant
people whom I'll talk about in a minute,
I can assure you. Uh, but also just
people that are afraid that, that, that,
you know,
they're met ta,
that there possibilities of their children
finding work in a country in which
work is very hard to find in which there's
no light at the end of the tunnel for
a very, very many young people, uh,
that all of this is, is going to happen.
And many people, many
ordinary people, not in Paris,
if you're working with the George Bush
dollar and try to afford a single, uh,
a cafe in Paris. Uh, but if for
very many ordinary people, the, the,
the year whole, that is the currency
that became, uh, January 1st year,
2002, I actually wrote something about
the transition of to that currency, um,
that, that this was the, this,
this currency, uh, to most people.
Seems like what you say in French is, and
I'll knock, it's a sting. Uh, it, it is,
all it's done is pushed up prices
and the government can try it out.
All the information they want to try to
show there hasn't been massive inflation
inflation due to the euro.
And that's simply false because things
that people buy in the, in their lives,
I don't mean rich people, but
I mean ordinary people, uh,
by have been become extraordinarily
high and expensive because of,
because of the whole, uh, and um, on the
other hand, my own personal thing is that,
look, I view the European
Union as, and this is, you
don't have to believe this. Uh,
uh, you can probably guess that
I would have this view. Uh,
I believe that a social
Europe might be kind of out,
could counterbalance the kind
of, of just runaway, you know,
bandit capitalism of the worst
excesses of capitalism. Uh,
and that, that, you know,
in America we live in,
I live in a country and we're civil
rights civic and civil rights are saluted.
But which human rights are,
there is no human rights are no
human rights in coded, uh, uh,
in the United States. Thus
Guantanamo Bay egg, thus a, you know,
exceptional rendering to torture
camps here and there. Uh,
because there isn't an assumption
that human rights counters that,
that civil rights is what counts
and the way you get civil rights,
it's becoming an American citizen
or permanent residents dust.
The big debate on which I'm not going
again too about immigration in this
country, which is a
very, very, a big debate.
But I always sort of viewed that
Europe would, well, you know,
if maybe he's a British would, would, um,
they didn't want to come along and they
don't want to get rid of the pound and
ended up all of this business.
But there's somehow the social Europe
with the basis of Germany and France,
whether it was parties, have the right or
part or senator or parties of the left,
would, you know, be this kind of block
that that would, would, would, uh,
would do what, what your, what the gall,
ironically here my singing the praises of
the goal of all people, uh, me, uh, uh,
you know, had, had, had that Europe could,
could have the role of Sir Francis
sort of this, there's honest broker in,
in a world now without that,
not to po big powers, but, uh,
but only one sort of
throwing its weight around.
And I don't even know what I think
anymore about that because, um, you know,
there are some advantages to Europe.
It's if you live in straws, boom.
If you live in Leone, you live in Paris,
well, you know, it helps the economy.
But if you live in the [inaudible] hall
or you living in a dash Dasho it doesn't
do a damn thing. It hasn't brought
anything at all to anyone. Uh,
as far as anyone can,
anyone can tell. Um, but,
and one of the things that
may go in the next years,
especially if Sarcozi gets his way and
one of the things that's dear to me
anyway, but I realized that there are
excesses is the providential state,
the idea of the welfare state,
which we read about and saw our
wines book and you all know exists.
And I've said this before
and I'll say it again.
If you don't have any
money and you're sick, uh,
you're a hell of a lot
better off if you know,
going to any doctor and you can pay 20
year old or 22 year old now, which is,
you know, every day more and more
in dollars, but a say now about $35.
If you get stuck and you
don't understand ratios,
they will keep you going and they will
help you if you're very rapport. But it,
there's a big sign that saying ratios
that said that the minimum charges $300 or
$400, I can't remember what
the big sign is. Um, now, um,
the health plan is terribly expensive and
there are all sorts of abuses. I mean,
there are people who,
for example,
have to go from where we live to Leon
to get treatment for this and that
sometimes very serious
illnesses and ambulance takes
them and the ambulance will
cost maybe a thousand dollars cost. The
health system was not thousand dollars.
Well, there are people around
the can drive them, uh,
and that kind of kind of situation.
And there are the unemployment
benefits are lavish to say the least.
There are people that,
that we know that our professional shomer
professionally unemployed that don't
do a damn thing and they don't want
to work and they never work. And,
and you know, it's probably is, uh,
you know, unfair but, but you know,
it's human beings, human rights. That's
something that they pay attention to.
They ought to have the right to a minimum.
And in France,
you called them or Amy's, they get a
really minimal little amount of money and,
uh, now they're strikes,
you know, they're,
the railroad workers go on
strike because they, they,
they want Dwight Dwight Dwight
[inaudible] that they acquired rights.
They ought to be able to,
I said this other day,
if you're driving a high speed Tj, fast
train, big pressure, you know, they,
they almost never crash hardly ever.
Uh,
but big pressure and that they think they
should have the right to retire at 55
or 50. Now this seems like it's a bit
of exaggeration to us in this country.
We don't even have a retirement age.
Um, and we don't have one at all.
It doesn't exist. Uh, so there were
abuses in all of this, but, but the,
the kind of total Americanization of,
of French social services would be,
in my view, a disaster. You
don't have to share that,
but that means there are abuses,
but you don't just have to
dismantle the whole thing. Uh, and,
and sort of turn it into an Americanized
version of this and that people are
always trying to measure happiness.
I have a student who wrote former student,
a great guy,
a ta this class now he's at Florida
state and wrote a book called happiness,
a history that did rather well.
It was on NPR and all this stuff.
And people are always trying to measure
how happy you are. And when they,
when they ask people in
France what makes them happy,
it's the right to have a vacation,
you know,
and you've got a lot of rich people in
this country who are very unhappy even
though they're,
they're loaded because they don't take
the time to have vacation and all this
and we can, you know, we can debate
the, we could go on and on about,
I could lapse into,
in the nostalgia for the next 10 hours
about the favorite meals I've had through
the, through the long hours into the early
morning with, with friends of ours and,
and, and how, you know, family
things together count and
your friends and all that.
But, but in France, you know, France
remains a, in many ways a happy place.
And in that,
because some of the anxiety is idea
of life has taken away by the state.
And I don't necessarily, I don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing.
What's going to happen though too,
to young people. Of course, you know,
I'm going to talk about
suburbs in a minute, but that's
part of it. It's not just,
it's not just, uh, an ethnic question.
It's not just a spatial question.
It's not just the unwanted people by
the center relegated to the margins of
urban life. Uh, it is also question
of what happens to young people,
not only young, a young, uh, uh, west
Africans are young, north Africans, uh,
or young people from the Caribbean, but,
but also young whites too because, uh, uh,
the unemployment rate,
uh, is, is always been,
it's considered a great success to have
the unemployment rate anywhere near 10%,
where sometimes as a 12, 13, and 14%.
And for all the faults of
this American system, uh,
we have where people don't declare their
unemployment often because they get
discouraged, but we have a much less,
uh, employment rate, uh, and, uh,
the chances of, of young people,
and not everybody goes to Yale, uh,
not everybody goes to Harvard or Princeton
or Wisconsin or Michigan or Oberlin
or, or Grinnell. You know, for a lot
of people that, you know, I mean,
they don't have those kinds
of options that you have. Um,
in France it's a much more
serious condition and there's
situation and people we
know that are very well educated,
they have no future and people we know
that they have no education, uh, you know,
are just scraping by to, and it's, uh,
uh, you know, the French economy remains,
it means a problem and maybe
Europe is in the long run,
it's going to help catapult a ordinary
people and not just a big capitalists,
big business people toward, toward a
better life. You know, I don't know. Uh,
but again, as I said, I encourage
my friends to vote against it.
We're not yet citizens, so
we, we, we couldn't vote. Uh,
we can't even vote in municipal
elections even though we've been legally
resident in France for,
for 20 years.
Meacham Hall and put forward that we
should be able to vote, not just us,
but everybody who illegal
residents because we have
an interest in what happens
in municipal life. Uh, but the high
court overthrew, overturned it,
but that's neither here nor there.
Now what about them?
What about but the riots and they
started up again the other day.
It would just very briefly when
these two kids were killed,
a young people that were our
kids, but yeah, they were young.
They were 15 and 16 when they
were, uh, killed, um, through
their own fault. Alas, uh,
uh, when they ran into a police car.
Uh, uh, but that, that was, these,
there were troubled in Toulouse,
but not very much trouble. Uh,
and that the trouble in this place called
Vva Lubell, uh, and in fairly soon, um,
in October and November,
I'm even two years ago and use
user were seniors are yours.
You were juniors ever will maybe remember
this and you could remember it if you
were in high school too.
Uh,
there were riots to began in the northern
suburbs of Paris and those who've been
to front Sloan into France
and flowing into Wasi. Uh,
when you landed at the airport,
Charles de Gaulle,
which they still insist on calling
Wasi, uh, you, um, you know, your,
your next thought is that w you know
what you'll do the first day in Paris,
whether it's seeing old friends again,
or where are you going to eat
or what you're going to visit.
Well around Wasi are not only he's
drawn see the transit camp where so many
people were in World War II were,
uh,
had to stay before they were set off
to the death camps to die. But they're,
they're the grim suburbs. And I, and
I, as I told you before, I explain why,
why French suburbs and other
European suburbs are very different.
They're just the opposite
of American suburbs.
They're largely the domain of people
unwanted by the center, by the center.
And this has been a, been a
tradition in France and other places.
There's a sense, uh, since the
ceased to become agricultural, uh,
truck farming communities
and became, uh, uh,
places where there were factories and
where there was a transient population and
it's been like that.
It was the worst trouble.
It's worst rioting in France
since 1968. Uh, we're a, um,
a year that we've already
talked about. Uh, again, the,
the precipitating event was a death of
two adult to adolescents who are 15 and
17. On October 27th, 2005.
This is only two years ago.
They had fled along with another person
who was very seriously wounded and was
taken care of by ironically, by the,
uh, coincidentally by the mother,
the mother of our, of our French Godson
at the Ob. Tell her while she knew a,
they were a bleed, they're being chased
by the cops in clichy suit. What?
P and C, l I. C h, a Su like underneath.
And then the block the woods.
They're know Wa left there underneath
housing projects because that's,
these were built in the
sixties and seventies.
Ain't no woods in Clichy Su walk.
Um,
and it populated population 28,300 people.
The sixth poorest commune in France,
70% of the population I live in
these housing projects in French,
the word is CT, c, I, t. E with an accent.
Now the first he tay were [inaudible].
They were created by a established
by Napoleon, the third in Paris.
Just a couple of you liked
the clip ribbons and that
was the end of it. Um, uh,
70% live who live in these projects,
which are just awful.
Um, are Muslims, like
the two boys who died,
they'd tried to hide in an electric
transformer and were grilled,
basically electrocuted. And the other
of the boy who survived had, um,
had burns over, you know, almost entirety
of his body. He's still alive. He lived.
Um, and so the incident and the events
that followed have to be seen in the
resentment that I've talked about
before and resistance of young people,
but in particularly minority
young people to the police,
to the crs and also to the
municipal police, uh, in, um,
the grub grim suburbs of Paris,
but also venture outside of a Lior
among others and outside of, of, uh,
of a Mousay, you know, where's he don
and the great, the great soccer player.
And as I said the other day,
the most,
still the most a respected person
admired person in France and Z.
Don grew up in such a project,
uh, and unlike Recia via,
he didn't have his picture taken,
the backed with his back in a
fancy suit to the project. He, uh,
he was proud of where he grew up and it
was part of his life. And he's, he's,
he's very good. Or if you follow French
soccer, there's no reason why he should.
But [inaudible] who's a great defense
player, who's an older guy now,
and he took it on Sarcozi after
this and start closing. You say,
what do you millionaire know
about the projects? And a,
and he took him on and he said,
you calling these people scum because
of who they are and because they live
there, and he says, I know the projects.
You don't know the projects and Sarcozi
doesn't go to the projects. Uh, cause he,
you know, anyway, that won't get off
on that. But we might, who knows. Um,
so in two months,
more than 9,000 cars were set ablaze
and 3000 people were arrested.
Most of those writing, uh,
writing where young, uh,
young minority males of
North African particularly,
but also west African, uh, uh,
my, uh, extraction along with,
uh, people from, you know,
Guadeloupe and Martinique and all sorts
of other places too. Uh, and as I,
as I argue the other day, I
mean, these are people who,
because they don't know Algeria, they
don't know Tunisia, they don't know Molly,
uh, they don't know synagogue. Uh,
they feel like they belong nowhere,
uh, because they don't share
the culture of their parents. I,
and they share with their
friends a culture of exclusion
that can also serve as
a way of, you know, of solidarity
a that the can also, uh,
in their language as I described
the other day. And, and,
and in these unfortunate advance a
show that they can stick together,
they can hang together to,
um,
and the trouble spread to the suburbs
of Leon to lead to sanity and the straws
booth and other places where you
can anticipate such reactions,
but also amazing enough to places like,
Aha, you know, and the lot, or in believe,
which isn't too far away. And just
all sorts of places or the hall, uh,
where you wouldn't think there'd be
anything in trouble, maybe described as,
you know,
lighting a poo,
bell of garbage can of blaze and throwing
it through a storefront or something
like that. That's not
a good thing to do. Uh,
but they spread to all sorts of places.
There was also an incident in Belgium, uh,
and which has a huge population from
x, Zaire, from, from, from Congo, uh,
and, uh, in Germany as well.
And most, most immigrants
in, in Germany, the majority,
not most,
but the majority of people who are there
are either from Turkey or now from,
from ex Yugoslavia, uh, and,
and Albania and the forms of resistance.
We're not themselves new hurling
Molotov cocktails and burning cars.
I mean, they say happened in, in straws
were for years. And it happens in Detroit.
Uh, you know, I said this the other day,
there had been riots and a much
more smaller scale in 1983, uh, uh,
and in 2000 and the town to mobile.
Yeah. Which is fairly near business.
So in the east, the
name doesn't matter. Um,
but there was violence,
more violence than before,
and it was directed, uh,
particularly against the police.
And the difference between those
incidents and the incidents now that have
occurred, uh, last week is
that people were using guns.
There isn't pistols and they're shooting
at the police and that takes it to a
different level. That didn't
happen. Uh, uh, two years ago,
and that's not a good sign.
Surprisingly, there was only a one desk,
a man who was beaten to death.
We'll trying to put out a fire, uh,
in a, in a place called staff,
which is a suburb of Paris.
And there were a few injuries. That's
all. Not very many for such big trouble,
lots of burned out cars, lots of anger.
The army was never called in. Um,
damage was, was surprisingly limited. Uh,
it was limited basically to cars, uh,
and a few shops and things like that.
There wasn't a to lose somebody
set the library and fire.
And this is what happened
in key. She, uh, in, um,
[inaudible] bell last
week as well. Uh, but, um,
there were occasional attacks on,
on churches.
I'd synagogues because there has
been a rise of antisemitism, uh, uh,
particularly in Muslim
communities. Uh, in France, it, I,
in contemporary France, there was an
attack on the Leon subway that may tool,
uh, and even against a stupidly a,
also against sporting facilities.
And France are not a lot of places
for young people to do sports.
And they've done been better
about that. Uh, you know, I mean,
sports are not exactly part of the program
and lycees and they run around the,
the,
you know,
the run around in the gym twice and
they're all the hacking and coughing and
grasping for their gold was, uh, but
you know, they've been doing better now.
And one of the reasons that said that
France does so well in soccer is because,
you know, they're, they, they take
particularly young minority, uh, uh,
youth who are very good,
good soccer players and they
get good training. And, and,
and that's why, you know, when fruit,
when we won the World Cup in 1998
and Joan Marie Le Pen said, ah,
the new leader of the National Front, he
said, he said it wasn't a French team.
That one. Why? Because
when you count it up,
there was Dominique because there's
no reason you should know this,
but there was picky. Uh, there was
a blog dorm, blah, who's from last.
Uh, there was, uh, uh, quite, uh,
quite slip in many ways,
uh, uh, about Tez, uh,
the goalie.
And did I forget somebody,
there was a guy who never
kept missing all the time. Um,
it was the name of what tall.
I can't remember who,
but the great players were two
homme is he don this psyche? Uh,
you know, the, the, these were the really
great ones. And so the Penn said, well,
that's not really France because
they may have French nationality,
but he doesn't count them as French. Uh,
because his, his racist view of the world,
which doesn't differ that much
from that event out off Hitler,
when push comes to shove,
they don't count. But happily,
most people in France
celebrated, uh, joyously, uh,
because they certainly
are French. Um, and,
and the damage was far less
than, for example, in La,
during the Rodney King, uh,
uh, riots in, in, in 1992 after the,
the police who beat up this guy
on camera, uh, beat up this,
this minority guy from
downtown La. You know, it's,
the La suburbs are not where the
d underprivileged people live.
They do not live in, in, uh, you know, uh,
the valley in the valley and all
that and all that kind of stuff. Um,
and when there were attacks on buildings,
they were attacks at night,
so nobody would be in, in the buildings
and the destruction of empty cars. Well,
so we'll stupid, you know, does
not, did not kill people. Now again,
I don't mean to sound like I'm defending
violence, but, uh, um, not a single,
despite the generalized hatred of the,
of the police,
not a single policeman was killed
or even seriously wounded. Uh,
though there were a few live round fire,
there were more policemen hurt the
other night, you know, were shot, uh,
hit by bullets. Then by then
happened, uh, uh, two years ago.
Um, so, um,
the government strategy of
criminalizing petty misdeeds,
I mean that seems to have worked in New
York. I guess that's what, you know,
Giuliani is going to stay over and
over again. Uh, the zero tolerance,
I mean the resting of people
who are hopping the metro,
getting on the Metro for
free and all of this, uh,
they tried that in France and that
may have increased the resistance,
the hatred of the police because
sometimes you, you know, you,
you see people get picked up when they're
trying to get through the metro and
you'll, you'll see police from there
and get on for free cause they don't,
they don't have any money. And,
uh, you know, when I let you know,
I let people through behind me if
they don't have any money and if they,
they look like they have money, then
I knock home about 20 feet back. Uh,
when I'm going through by stopping
or knock on backwards. We very nice.
But I believe in public
transportation. Uh, anyway,
but the SRAP government had eliminated
funds not only for voluntary associations,
uh,
but for the kind of beat policing that
has worked in many areas in it, you know,
and sometimes in this country that in
tough neighborhoods where they've been a
lot of problems by having the policeman
become part of the community and
therefore not just seem
like a foreign presence,
but that's not the case in [inaudible].
And that's not the case in Boban knee.
That's not the place in Qube
of y and places like that.
Or in Venice who outside,
uh, of lean all there. When the police
are there, they're not the same guys.
And when they're there, they're
the ones saying, you know,
your papers, your papers,
your papers, or they don't go at all
and they don't protect the other people.
I mean, most of the crime that
occurs there is that, you know,
are minorities against minorities because
of the sheer numbers and the police.
One of the complaints there is the
police aren't there to help anybody.
And when they do,
they come in huge numbers.
It's up against the wall
baby and that kind of stuff.
So the rise took on a political
dimension. And here I get again, I'm, I'm,
I'm saying I, I'm not trying to give
a political interpretation into this.
This is a fact. I mean, this is what
happened. Um, and Nick and equalizer,
I z the minister of Interior,
um,
he manipulated the situation.
He referred to the writers,
this riff Raff or even scum Rokaya a
word that I've used before, how Chi scum,
which can, you know, I can also be
tough guy, but, but it means scum more.
And he said,
well,
we knew need to do is get these big hoses
that they use this as brand that you
clean out gutters specifically
for cleaning out gutters.
We have to get these hoses and get rid
of them, get them out of the gutters.
So who's down? You know, these are
people who are non whites, who are poor,
who live in the suburbs, who are
condemned, where marginalized. Uh, uh,
the words suburb even lost is
neutral sense in the French language.
Long ago at the end of the 19th century.
I did a book on this a long time ago
and I just don't that word but on,
on some of this stuff. Um, and so, uh,
that he said that suburb should be
disinfected to get rid of this gum.
And I'm not being too over the top to
say that, uh, you know that you, you it,
his few years scum, this is
son of immigrants. By the way,
when you're an immigrant,
you're scum because you exist because
you're there because you're not rich.
And when he got elected that
he gets his big vacation.
And in Multa spending as much money
as humanly possible to say, well,
if you work hard like me, fall,
say they won't say, phone says you,
you will become rich to,
well, it ain't that easy.
It seemed like a blatant attempt
to win the supporters who,
who exported the violent extreme right
of a John Marie Le Pen and after election
law, Penn said all these
things, what we've said,
he said it to be sure in
a more tactful way. Uh,
he does not believe that the camps were
a minor. The death camps were a minor,
minor detail in the history of World
War II, which is what Lopez said.
He doesn't believe
that. Uh, and he didn't,
he would not give some nodding approval
when some of his thugs drown Moroccans
in the, in the, uh, in
the, in the sen, you know,
after Joan of Arc Day March,
Joan of arc, they march, uh,
and sort of say, well, you know, boys
will be boys and this kind of stuff. Um,
but he took the, the rhetoric of
racism and made it respectable.
And then you don't have to agree
with this, but this is my view.
This is what happened. That's
what happened. That's it.
It was a strategy that Charlotte Pasqua
who had been in Ministry of Interior
long ago and tried to use and hidden, not
worked, but it worked this time around.
Now again, I don't exaggerate
the problem of, of, uh, you know,
there has been increased criminality.
There've been attempts to prove that the,
that the greater increases of
criminality, uh, uh, Eh, you know, uh, uh,
Shay lately, you know, with,
with immigrant populations and non
immigrant populations, uh, you know, it,
that's hard to say whether
that's true or not.
We're not talking about
crime waves like you, like,
like lots of murders and things like that.
France still operates on
a very civilized, uh, uh,
a scale in part because they have
very harsh gun laws. Uh, and it's,
you can't just sort of a, it'd
be 15 and not old enough to, uh,
to vote are old enough to
drink in this country. Uh,
but you're old enough to buy
a machine gun practically, uh,
and that sort of thing. Uh,
to hum a t, t, h, u r m,
whom I mentioned a while
ago, the, the, the, uh,
footballer or denounced the remarks is
contemptuous and humiliating serving to
awaken latent racism in France.
And he got that right.
And shock shock is usual, tried to, uh,
more concerned with his bank
accounts in Japan or whatever,
tried to remain above.
And the indictment,
which subsequently has followed
up in his indictment yet,
but all the scandals when
he was mayor of Paris,
he tried to remain above
the fray. Uh, he, uh,
had the declaration of the
state of emergency on November
8th red to journalists
on his behalf instead of
actually reading it himself.
But he seemed to be as he was in the end,
more and more ineffective,
isolated and virtually ignored,
rather like his predecessor
Charles de Gaulle in 1968 in 1969,
um, one of the one minister
on the center, right, uh,
said that one of the reasons this is all
happening isn't the suburbs is polygamy.
That was his, his definition for what
happened. Uh, Sarcozi the other day said,
this is not a social
crisis in the suburbs.
What, not a social crisis. It's a
crisis. It's an enormous social crisis.
He said that he referred to a voyeur to,
uh,
a thug ocracy a thug autocracy,
and there's no social crisis.
The social crisis is that,
that huge percent of the
population living in France,
particularly 5 million Muslims, but not
just 5 million Muslims, more than that,
you're not feel part of France and
are not integrated in France. Uh,
in part because of,
of special considerations where they live,
lack of opportunity also because
of discrimination and lack of,
of, of low opportunity. The same
that other people have had. Um,
it's hard to get people to
teach in the stem stem knee.
That is the department of number 93. When
you say catch around class, which means,
uh, the sentence underneath, which is,
has many of these places you can't get
teachers to teach there because there is
violence, you know, not big time
violence, but there's, there's,
there's violence and the whites out
there. Of course. Uh, uh, not all of them.
And many of them vote, uh, uh, uh,
national front and they voted
for Sarcozi massively. Uh,
this was discovered actually about
10 years ago also that in some of the
neighborhoods in Paris said Monaca and
then the 18th and 20th thrown these small
bubbles bubble on the 20th that the white
population voted overwhelmingly, uh,
in some areas for, uh, for the,
the, the National Front, uh, in,
in part because they,
you know,
they were afraid of the fact that they
would be minorities in there are in their
own cal ta and all of this.
And you also had this crossover vote
between the old communist party white
workers voting for the national
front as well. And you found that in,
in places in the north of France. And
you found that in other places. Um, it,
it's given all this, it's surprising
that the trouble is, didn't come, uh, uh,
before, uh, because, uh, the, the, the,
the immigrants as you know,
really were attracted to France in larger
numbers by the booming economy, uh,
in the 1960s. And all of this slowed down
at a time that I can remember with the,
uh, the, uh, the oil crisis
of 73 and 74, which is just,
we don't, when I was, and I got to Yale
when that much older than you guys, uh,
that, uh, that was, that, that
stopped it. And suddenly all
the people that, you know,
all the announcements have come to France,
we'll find you a job posted
in Tunis and, and, uh, uh,
Jay and Matt cash and Fez and
all these places, uh, uh, those,
those were taken down.
And, and, uh, and uh,
they're there and the
economic slowdown came,
but there were fewer jobs awaiting goes
people and their descendants and the
Muslim population of Francis
now about 5 million people.
One of the interesting things also is
that there was no really way of counting
the number of people of any
ethnic origin in France.
There is none because it's illegal
to ask on a census what is,
what are your ethnic origins?
You can't do that.
So there's no official way
of counting up now that,
that then France can say,
we have no,
we have no ethnic crisis.
But also you can't,
they, they can say that, which isn't true.
Uh, I mean, hello. That's just isn't true.
But also the problem is if
you don't know where all the,
where you have strong ethnic
minorities or even majority's,
then you can't really go out and try
to solve the problem because you're not
really sure. Municipals statistics are
much more accurate, but there's no,
I don't know,
any global kind of statistics,
but they think they're above about five,
uh,
a million people and many
of them live in the suburbs,
live in these Asha LMS. They're
called, uh, uh, [inaudible] or, or,
or, uh, well see tay, you know, their,
their housing projects. Uh, uh, basically,
uh, and in which, um, uh, so
many of the people are poor,
many depend on,
on state assistance and crowd more
and more relatives than tiny spaces.
We knows how a good number
of people from Zaire, uh,
who were brought to to France thanks to a,
a French friend of ours,
a lawyer and some of them
came as basketball players,
a couple of them did and you know,
they're living in rooms out in the
suburbs and they, they're, you know,
15 people living in a, in a, in a
small apartment. Um, and what are,
and so the rate of unemployment in France
in 19 2005 was about 10, about 10%,
3 million unemployed.
That's a lot. But a young,
young people among young people
is 23% and in the suburbs, uh,
uh,
then employment weight rate rose from
28% to 40% for young people between 1990
and 2000.
And the unemployment rate for foreigners
and French with origins in non European
countries stood at about 36%
of the population in Clichy.
This community that I said was the
fifth or whatever I said sixth poorest
community in France.
I think fifth at the time 80% of the
population lived in what were classified
are classified still as a zone.
Then small Siebler,
difficult urban zones and 35% in public
housing in Clichy Suwon the unemployment
rate for young people between
18 and 25 your age stood at 60%,
and for 33% of the population as a whole.
And there were constant complaints
when all their journalists would go in,
the reporters go, Eh, you
know, [inaudible] was sent
out reporters and, and,
and they counted all these
stories of their lives.
They're trying to find jobs and with the
same qualifications being turned down
systematically and they've done all these,
they've done,
they've done these secret things. I've
seen this on TV where they'll take people,
uh, you know, and,
and set up companies in a way to see how
they react when they're confronted by
candidates for a job,
uh, in which, you know,
the white person will be less well
qualified than the north African or a west
African. And time and time again, just
write down the line, wouldn't get the job,
wouldn't. And there's no use. There's no
use ignoring this fact, even as Sarcozi,
uh, uh, says it, uh, that
this, this isn't true.
And many of them are particularly those
people from north and west Africa,
depending on this informal economy,
a economy of barter in economy of,
of, you know, black marketing to, uh,
to an extent or, or petty drug
deals and things like that. Uh,
because there's nothing else, uh, to do
a man of Arab origin. Put it this way,
he says, I raised my
children, hiding from them.
The fact that I no longer
have any hope for them,
but the real drama is that
they understand all of that.
They grew up in this bloody
chaos and they suffer.
There is no future for the
children of immigrants here.
That's a tough thing to say. And
that's not, that was a thoughtful,
it's not just somebody who
is reacting to, to, uh,
into a city in flames and to violence
between the police and young people.
Uh,
it's somebody who's who for whom
that experience was a part of,
uh, of, uh, of their lives. And he's
reflecting the fact that, I mean,
in this interview, when I wrote to all
of this, I wrote this for a piece, uh,
you know, I was doing it,
you know, reading magazines.
That's how you know that are you
doing kind of instant history.
I wrote this just a couple weeks after
this happened for an encyclopedia,
a while, maybe six months
after that, you know, you,
you end up reading things
like this, but, but,
but if this is a form of history also,
uh,
and he's reflecting the gap between
himself and his own children,
they don't believe that
they belong anywhere.
If you don't believe you belong
anywhere, you know, then then, you know,
then society's got a big a problem.
And they say that they don't feel French
and they've been controlled so many
times. It's not just their control.
Once in a while or some, you know,
a zealous policemen sees a west African
and north African and says, Hey, hey,
let me see your papers, man. Uh,
it's just time and time again.
And I told you the other day that,
you know, I never am crow. I'm never,
never controlled anywhere.
Never, never, never.
And I've been leaving metro stations
with all sorts of people were, you know,
Barbara's Roy Schwartz and places like
that with all sorts of people who are
minorities and, and more French
than I am, more French than I am.
And I have a residence card.
I don't have a passport,
and they have passports and
there are ones are controlled.
It's not me that's controlled.
And I don't dress in differently than
they do as you might've been able to tell.
Uh, and it, it, uh, the recent law against
Foula, you know, against the headscarves.
So, which has been much to do.
And My friend Joan Scott just has,
who lectured up here a couple of weeks
ago. Hey, you know, this also, I mean,
my argument, not everybody agrees
with me, not even people on the left,
some of them don't agree with
me, but, but, uh, um, you
know, you can twist and say,
well,
this and not twisted,
but you can take the take on it that
this is really an antifeminist thing.
It's anti women's thing. People wearing
full hour. And I generally feminist, uh,
but not necessarily. Why not? Uh, that
I think it's anti Muslim. Uh, they say,
well, you know, you can't wear
big crucifixes in the class to a,
you can't worry Yamakas in the
class. Well, I don't know. Uh,
my kids have been in the say a
[inaudible] near to lose and then, um,
uh, Marcel Gimo and Oba and a, they
knew or saw me wearing huge crucifixes.
Uh, no crude, big crucifix is allowed. Uh,
I'm not sure if they've seen Yamikas
that is a problem because they had the
right there, the growth of antisemitism
and not just among Muslim populations,
but it's directed against Muslims. There's
no question about it. Uh, in my view.
And furthermore, that, I mean,
you can understand the
position of some Muslim women.
I'm not saying anything about, uh, why
people were fooled. I mean, I don't know,
but there's some are under pressure from
their fathers or their older brothers
to wear headscarves. And
that's very, you know,
one can understand these
family situations. I'm not
saying anything about this,
but I think that, that, that, that this is
a law that is aimed at Muslims. I think,
uh, you can invoke the secular
republic, you can look,
invoke the separation of church and state.
You know,
we talked about that this country went
to the inauguration and north haven,
Connecticut of,
uh,
our dear friend who was just
elected select when the other day,
and it was supposed to be separation of
church and state. And they were, you know,
there were prayers and they
were in vocations and all
of this business. Uh, but I,
I see this as directed at Muslim women
because they are Muslims and other people
don't agree with me, but I think, but
this has been a lightning rod for,
for the way that people treat each other.
And who has the right to be who they
are in, you know, in France. Um,
and as I said,
the French Republic has even refuse
to acknowledge the existence of ethnic
groups. They're not counted, they're not
countable. And part of that, as I said,
is that you don't want to make people
feel different by saying you are so many
people from muddy.
You are so many people from Senegal.
You are so many people from, with
Algerian background, uh, or whatever. Uh,
but,
uh,
what the government did is talk about
the necessity of order of imposing order.
And that's what he talks about,
his order and the police
in order La Fosse daughter.
And there's no talk much
anymore about equality. Uh,
and it gets lost in this is that old
French commitment to human rights,
which is something that
one can only value.
And given that the total degradation of,
of views of human rights in, in, in, uh,
in, uh, you know, well, we'll
get into this, but in, in this
country, uh, recently, uh,
I, um, you know, when could
only a wonder, it's amazing. Um,
and ironically the state of emergency
that was declared in 2005 in the fall was
based on the state of siege law that
had been imposed in 1955 during the
Algerian war of independence to try to
impose order on Algerians who want it to
be free and they use the same law
without any kind of, oh, excuse a new,
and we were very sorry this law,
we understand this is a different
situation or is it, who knows? Uh, and uh,
it was this fact was not
lost on Arab minorities. Uh,
the Portuguese immigrants may be the
largest single national ethnic or other
from other places group in
the Paris region, but it,
but Algerians are not far
away and what this riots did,
and this is a good place to end since
we can do we have to end, uh, is it a,
made clear that in the civil that there's
been a breakdown in civil society,
in the fringe suburbs and that
obviously something has to be done.
And there's been a lot of talk about
how we're going to pump more money into
voluntary associations,
but nothing has been zen zen Ho.
That's what people said the
other day. Uh, the red belt, uh,
remains, uh, uh, uh, you know,
a dream of the past. Nope.
They're communist party is hardly, no, no
one's out there defending these people.
There are no political parties. There's
the SLS Ross season, uh, uh, Harlem, uh,
uh, Daisia is an old group. Uh, but
I've yet to see a political party, uh,
embraced the cause of these
people. The way, for example,
even the communist party embraced
the cause of, of, of, uh,
the small percentage of French peasants
that is 8% or 5%. Even now, uh,
in, uh, uh, left in France. Um,
and the credits that had been locked
off by the previous government,
US still have never have
never been returned.
Um, there aren't enough funds
at the moment to create jobs.
He tried to create
these employ young jobs.
Do they call them the people
to help old ladies on with her,
on the trains where their suitcases, but
these are temporary work. You know, there,
I mean, the problem is, uh,
is an enormous problem and it's not
something you can kind of be drempt away,
like saying, well, they are
out there and you know, Paris,
we'll still have all of this American
and English and German and Belgian
visitors because they don't go with the
Clichy Suwon they go to look at north
for dom and the Eiffel Tower.
And when they fly over places like Sar
Salar or Gosh, Mulago Ness, you know,
they don't pay much attention to it. And
so one, one thing that people have to do,
and I suppose this is what I'm doing
now, uh, is that one can only, Eh, uh,
you know, encourage public awareness
of the kind of marginalization of,
of lots of people. You can't turn Europe
into sort of fortress Europe. You know,
you can't imagine the kind of thing
that the Americans want to do or some
Americans want to do.
Build this huge wall,
a new Berlin Wall between
Mexico and the United States.
You know what they going to do
in Paris, but a huge, huge wall,
run the peripheral leak,
uh,
have the highway running around Paris
and then leaving it open to Versailles of
course, and the fancy suburbs
on the, uh, on the west. Um, so,
uh, for a moment, I mean a lot
of people in 2005 at the end,
or if you ask him in 2006,
you ask young people even to participate
in who said garbage can on fire.
What do you think has come out of this?
The,
the ones who were most charitable
about all of this said that look, uh,
with commodities is that we've tried
to make France and w and the world and
Europe people, they had to comfortable
places to don't think about these issues,
uh, uh, aware of these problems. But
this isn't a problem that's going to,
it's going to go away. And once you can
see it as a problem, it's a challenge. Uh,
and uh, because they, you know,
France believes deeply in the tradition
in this course, uh, the, of course,
you know what I mean? The, the history of
France and Liberty Fraternity, equality.
And there's the times when push comes
to shove and you have to actually show
that you mean it. So, uh, hopefully
France will remain France. Uh,
but hopefully this situation will improve,
but it's going to take a lot of action
and not just kind of polarizing talk and
appealing to two electorates who just
want the whole problem to go away. Um,
your final moment yet go away.
And I want to thank you for taking this
course and I'm going to put these things
outside and you can sign up and
once you sign up, you're signed up.
So be sure to know where you're
supposed to go for your final. Okay.
And have a wonderful break and have a
wonderful end of the semester and see you,
see you around email next semester.
Take it easy.